there really isn't another place that
I'd rather live and another place that
you can get the kind of inspiration that
you can get here there's so many
different cultures here how everything
kind of meets in its pulling from all
these different directions I think gives
people a unique perception on the world
in a unique vantage point there's not
too many other places you can go on
earth and have all of the different
dynamics of the city of Los Angeles our
personal story is synonymous with the
downtown story we were an emerging
company we had no real history and
nobody really believed in it people
don't think we'd get to where it is now
where did the emergent rain come down
downtown we want to plan our routes in
LA and really make the city ours you go
to each different city across the world
and each place has its own style
I think la is that perfect blend it's
more casual but it's an elevated casual
aesthetic I'm pretty particular about a
lot of things I really like burb coffee
I like nitro cold brew I love to work
out I love playing ping pong I love
bowling
to me Los Angeles the greatest in the
world there's so many different types of
people here we travel all the time but
there's no better feeling than landing
back in LA